we learned that corporate media failed
progressives in the 2016 election what
media loved was the fact that Trump
would say one absurd thing after another
ugly things about people that we've
never heard before from a presidential
candidate that was great TV the American
people have got to demand more out of
media the American people have got to
demand that media talk about the issues
that impact our likes corporate media
could not have failed us more acutely
they ignored Bernie Sanders until they
had no choice they reported timidly
about the outrageous ideas of Donald
Trump and we cannot just be wandering
aimlessly for strategy and candidates to
move the country forward and we
absolutely cannot accept the hate that
has risen in the wake of Donald Trump's
election we need to create real
progressive engagement and that is
exactly one of the things that we're
seeking to do with this campaign we need
to enable progressives to take action we
must have a plan the david pakman show
has one and i want you to be a part of
it i actually need you to be a part of
it we built a successful independent
media platform at the david pakman show
but the show alone is simply not enough
so we are launching a major campaign to
not only fundamentally grow our reach
but also to grow the influence of
progressive media in some extraordinary
new way this campaign will allow us to
number one hire a progressive engagement
coordinator to organize and coordinate
the rest of action on issues and
candidates that matter we are going to
organize and partner with existing
independent progressive chose to
coordinate activism and exponentially
increase the impact of our efforts we're
going to upgrade the david pakman show
studio to the next level of
professionalism including a real
professional set design as well as
professionalizing the guest interview
technology platform and we're also going
to bring the david pakman show to amazon
crime this is just a huge opportunity to
reach a much larger audience it has
significant heck and staff requirements
and its extensive enough that it exceeds
current staff capacity
and we're going to create a true david
pakman show mobile broadcast capability
right now I can basically skype into the
Boston studio from remote locations
which is very limiting in a lot of ways
and to truly do remote broadcasts from
areas where activism is happening we
need the ability to edit and distribute
the program remotely and that will
greatly increase our ability to be
activists and additionally we are going
to start developing long-form interview
content with brilliant progressive minds
in-person interviews with people who
truly can equip us to be change agents
and also to teach us how to most
effectively lobby for progressive change
I need your support please look at the
perks that we are offering look at the
fundraising goal and make the largest
contribution you can you also can refer
donors to the campaign we've got a
referral contest which you can read
about towards the bottom of the campaign
page and you can use the Facebook and
Twitter buttons on the campaign page to
refer donors to the campaign that is
also absolutely huge if there's anything
we can do to engage you or people in
your network to become donors please
don't hesitate to ask because there's
just too much riding on this this is the
biggest initiative we've ever done and
I'm asking for your help to make it
happen